let's get to five headlines
[Music]
you know as part of our daily wire
audience there are a number of ways to
get uh to take in the podcast you can
listen on apple podcast you can
go to spotify you can go to another
podcast app you can also watch our
podcast on youtube facebook over at
dailywire.com bottom line
our content is available in a lot of
places and there's no excuse not to
watch it i mean a personality personally
offends me
if you miss an episode if you don't
watch it hurts me deeply on a personal
level and
of course needless to say i am oppressed
um
every person who does not watch this
show is oppressing me so i'm being
oppressed by
you know billions of people and now
we're introducing a new upgraded
experience though daily wire is now on
apple tv and roku so members can enjoy
all of the visual elements on this
podcast on your big screen either live
or on demand find the daily wire app on
apple tv or roku
and download today go to dailywire.com
walsh
use code watch at checkout to get
15 off your memberships one five percent
off your membership deals
uh it's not it's not gonna it's not
gonna last long so you gotta go now
and uh you can watch apple tv or roku
all
you know just just more opportunities to
avoid uh oppressing me
that's really the headline here okay now
number one huge news here nancy pelosi
is the victim of a setup a sting
operation
a ruse probably the russians are behind
it we can assume
there was there was some kind of vast
conspiracy afoot and the result of the
conspiracy is that nancy pelosi
got her hair done as we discussed
yesterday pelosi was caught
uh you know getting her hair done inside
a san francisco salon which is illegal
according to the lockdown you know the
lockdown that she supports
and has insisted upon but she went in
nobody else can but she did she went and
got a blowout a blowout which apparently
i'm told is the same thing as a blow-dry
now why do we call it a
blowout if it's just a blow-dry why do
you need to go to a salon
and pay someone to use a hair dryer
can't you do it yourself these are all
questions that
still are left unanswered um and
also you know how is it that nancy
pelosi even still has hair at the age of
732.
another there's a lot of mysteries here
that are that are going on
um but she went in nonetheless and she
got her her hair done
now the the assumption
from a lot of people no doubt many of
them probably sexist
the assumption is that nancy pelosi did
something wrong you know by defying
lockdown orders
uh assuming that the laws didn't apply
to her and so on well she was asked
about this
uh during a press conference and she
explained
that no no no no she is the real victim
here
listen i take responsibility for
trusting
the word of the neighborhood salon that
i've been to over the years
many times and that when they said what
we're able to
accommodate people one person at a time
and that we can set up that time i
trusted that
as it turns out it was a setup so i take
responsibility
for falling for a setup and that's all
i'm going to say
on that i take responsibility for the
fact
that i am not responsible i take
responsibility
for being a tr a trusting kind
faultless angel who was exploited by
nefarious hair stylists who in their
free time i have learned just so you
know
do in fact drown kittens for fun and
cannibalize the elderly
i'm just lucky to have escaped with my
life uh and plus my hair looks gorgeous
you have to admit that's just to
summarize what she just said there
uh in other words she's you know all
joking aside a horrible human being
i guess that's that's how we can con
conclude this
let's go to number two uh checking in
with the gaff machine joe biden here's
his latest
what they're calling a quote unquote
gaff listen
ahead of your trip to kenosha wisconsin
tomorrow
last week your running mate senator
harris said that the officer who shot
jacob blake
based on what she has seen should be
charged do you agree with her and do you
also believe the same for the officers
who were involved in the death of
brianna taylor
i think we should let the judicial
system
work its way i do think there's a
minimum need to be charged the officers
and
as well as brianna taylor and uh i might
add by the way i think
what happened in uh in portland
where a one of the
trump guys riding along in vans and
citing response
is shooting rubber bullets i guess or
paintballs
apparently there was someone shot by
someone in the crowd with a bullet
killed i think that person should meet
the legal requirements that whatever
that calls for
we should be investigated and it should
follow through on what needs to be
done let the judicial system work
let's make sure justice is done so the
gap is supposed to be that joe biden
said brianna taylor needs to be charged
that's what he said there
um but that's not really the point uh
the the point is that joe biden is
calling for charges of officers who
according to all of the evidence we have
seen acted appropriately
to preserve the lives of innocent people
not just themselves but the other people
around the kids in the car
that the knife-wielding violent accused
domestic abuser and rapist was trying to
get into
to evade arrest they also act to protect
them
that's all the evidence we have but
biden because he's
not a good person and he's a coward and
a fraud and a weak man
has no problem throwing the officers to
the wolves
to score points politically we think
about this this guy is 78 years old
at the tail end of his life one way or
another okay 78
um and this is what he wants his final
chapter to be
appeasing a violent mob taking the side
of criminals against cops
throwing innocent men to the wolves all
in pursuit of a position of power
that he's barely conscious enough even
to appreciate
sad pathetic disgraceful but you know
all that aside
uh we did learn during the convention
that he likes vanilla ice cream with
sprinkles so
he's got that going for him at least
number three let's go to some uplifting
and happy news today from the daily wire
um a so-called antifa commander who
reportedly was armed dropped to the
ground and began crying in the fetal
position
when law enforcement officers stopped
him at a riot and placed him under
arrest
this is something something a little
something to lift our spirits a little
bit this is nice
matthew banta 23 was arrested at a riot
late last week after he allegedly
ignored police commands and has been
charged with two counts of felony bail
jumping
and one count of obstructing an officer
the green bay press gazette reported
quote the charges
stemmed from a report about 9 pm
saturday that a whole bunch of white
people with sticks baseball bats and
helmets
were headed towards the police who were
trying to break up what they deemed an
unlawful assembly in downtown green bay
following a protest saturday afternoon
uh so and you can see the commander
there
scary guy very tough looking this guy
apparently is
known for instigating violence all the
time he does that
in between his shifts at the t-mobile
kiosk from the looks of it
of course i'm joking there's no way he
has a job these losers don't have jobs
but it goes to show you know we call
antifa dangerous
and they are only because huge
crowds of people with weapons and and uh
and guns and bats
and no moral compass are always
dangerous right
no matter how pitiful and scrawny they
are on an individual level
but that doesn't say that these people
individually are
are tough you know you can give bats and
guns to a bunch of five-year-olds and
they would be
certainly a danger um
most of these antifa brats individually
are just
scared pitiful weaklings
and this is a game to them all the
cosplay conventions are shut down
because of
kovid so this is what they're doing
instead and that's why it has to be made
real you arrest them put them in prison
on real charges real prison time
and they could see this is not just a
game okay number four
the congealed lump of semi-sentient
oatmeal currently presiding as
mayor of portland ted wheeler is moving
away from his 840 000
condo because it's been targeted so
often by rioters
remember though there's no violence no
problem in portland
everything's fine says wheeler as he
speeds away in his moving van in the
middle of the night
um the story of ted wheeler is really a
sad one
you know first of all as has already
discussed
at some point in his life a witch put a
curse on him and turned him into
a lump of oatmeal so that was his first
tough break and then he's elected mayor
and he does
everything in his power to legitimize
the rioters provide cover for them
aid and abet them in their terrorism
he's doing everything he can for them
everything you can
hands the city over to them and says
here here you go burn it to the ground
do what you want and they still hate him
they still hate him
even after all of that uh yeah
i'm sure he's thinking himself what can
i what else can i do for you people
and the answer is no it's never enough
ted
that's the answer maybe you've seen that
by now
number five and in our most important
story of the day uh david blaine
floated away in a balloon and was never
seen
again actually i'm not sure if that
happened i didn't watch
did anybody watch david blaine did his
balloon stunt yesterday i feel like
nobody watches i didn't see anything
about it online nobody was talking about
it
the guy makes you know he goes out in
the middle of the desert with a balloon
and floats away just nobody cares or is
watching
somebody looks out their window and says
oh is that david blaine flip well all
right that gets back to what they were
doing
um they live streamed the youtube live
stream david blaine floating on balloons
and uh it was like a three hour live
stream
i mean did would anyone sit there for
three hours and watch a guy floating on
a balloon i don't know
now they called this stunt ascension
that's what they called it
and at first when i heard that blaine
was gonna do a stunt called
ascension i thought okay well
you know this is gonna be a trick where
he uh
flies and and nobody can figure out how
he's doing it
you know something like that that's what
it's really what i thought it would be
and i thought that that's pretty cool
uh but then i learned no he's just
floating with balloons
how is that why is that impressive
humans have been floating on balloons
since like the 1700s the first
the first hot air balloon flight was in
the 1700s
this dude is 300 years late with this
trick
what is he going to invent the wheel
next
is he going to ride down the street in a
bicycle
behold as he rides his huffy down the
street i don't know
i feel like this had to be the backup
stunt this there must have been
something else they wanted to do that
was really cool
and they couldn't do it and so at the
last minute they said
well you know you could uh float
with balloons and they just decided to
do that but anyway congrats to david
blaine for floating i hope that
he made it down safely well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content